i never talked about for three years
even in toronto
my dad got sick
christmas
2018.
my last year in toronto my dad got sick
went in the hospital i flew home a
couple days before christmas
except my dad and he was in he was in
the hospital
for the next in and out the hospital the
next three years after that so from
three years
i was i then flew from boston to la la
to toronto by myself played in the game
did the same thing in san antonio but
nobody never knew it was times i flew in
and did a game and played
from seeing my dad
say so
leave la fly in
game day and play that night
at night i did it so many times
countless times i never talked about it
never talked about it i mean how
difficult was that when you were making
these trips and then having to it was it
was it was it was the most
it was probably the hardest thing in my
life to do because
you know you
you have so much idol time of sitting on
the plane by yourself
dealing with the emotional like
like trauma of seeing your dad seeing
the person that only person in life i
ever feared
you know down and out
to have having to go play in front of 20
000 people
you know it was like the emotional
roller coaster that i dealt with for you
know three years was
was one of the toughest things ever
because one i never wanted to be a
distraction
to to my teammates
to to the game and nothing so you know i
dealt with everything i dealt with
personally and i didn't want to be loud
about it i didn't want nobody
necessarily feel sorry for me and
everything but i also wanted to be there
for my teammates
um in my family you know what i mean so
to carry those emotions consistently
you know behind the scenes that nobody
knew you know it was it was
it was tough like it was tough like even
even when i lost my dad i was in a hotel
in charlotte like just finished playing
the game
fly home
you know
home a couple days and i flew back with
the team playing the game fly back home
go to the funeral leave the shooting
complaining you know it was like all
those emotions to where
and then
what really made it hard you know like i
said i'm sitting on the plane by myself
for hours like
you know with this on your mind trying
to figure out how all right how you
gonna
balance yourself out to be able to play
tonight you know but i needed to play
like i said my teammates guys i played
with
knew what i was going through and that
was always there for me and they made it
easy for me and that's why i always felt
like i had to be there for for them as
well yeah to compete um so yeah that was
for three years